[Música]
massachusetts se llevó la peor parte de
la tormenta mientras el noreste de los
estados unidos fue golpeado por fuertes
vientos decenas de miles de personas se
quedaron sin servicio eléctrico boston
empató su récord de la mayor cantidad de
nieve en un solo día con 60 centímetros
un récord está alcanzado por última vez
en 2003
en este momento están cayendo unos pocos
centímetros por hora siete centímetros y
medio por lo menos se está haciendo
pesado otras ciudades también luchan con
el clima extremo como nueva york donde
el nuevo alcalde eric adams les dijo a
los residentes que deben permanecer en
interiores para evitar lo que los
meteorólogos llamarán un ciclo bomba si
tiene que salir hoy y quiere hacerlo en
transporte público este ferry es una
excelente manera de subir y llegar a
station island o de state island para
llegar a manhattan pero escuche
cuidémonos quedémonos fuera de las
carreteras hagamos lo correcto
el mal tiempo en algunas partes de 10
estados seguirá afectando el tráfico
aéreo este domingo con cientos de vuelos
ya cancelados
mientras tanto algunos turistas
aprovecharon la nieve para divertirse